il y avait le spectacle de malik
bentalha alors beaucoup de gens
pensaient que ça a été un énorme carton
je crois même que si reed penser à des
très très très très bien marché il n'a
pas marché du tout non que l'on puisse
dire mon cher kevin vatant ben non ça
n'a pas marché du tout 1 million 800
mille téléspectateurs armes il y en a 1
millions 9,6 on voulait arrondir mais
ils s'attendaient vraiment beaucoup
parce que kev adams est la version en
direct il avait réalisé trois millions
en éternel on aime ça mais après c'est
le jeudi et il s'est fait battre par m6
par france 2 domanick bentalha excuse
moi c'est très parisianisme
honnêtement c'est pas un humoriste
aujourd'hui la france entière connaît ou
suivent pas mais la semaine dernière il
mettait je crois pascal obispo sur tmc
et ça pour le concert et là il met ma
limite à la courneuve beaucoup mais
c'est vrai que entame de toi mais tf1
bien sûr apprécié la vérité sur dmc ça
aurait été un succès tout de suite oui
non mr en plus enfin faut dire faut dire
ce qui est c'est la cible c'est quoi de
malik bentalha c'est plus les jeunes
pour l'âge de mon fils
hier je regarde elle était tout excité
c'est vrai que kiev 1 a vachement miser
sur la promotion toute la semaine ils en
ont parlé attention je dis attention je
dis attention je dis mais à la fin c'est
les jeunes c'est la clientèle chez les
jeunes ya beaucoup de deux petites
références comme ça aux jeunes si tu as
50 60 mallette est pour mais lui il a
fait une comme de fou avec les réseaux
sociaux même clients n'aiment pas fait à
partager tout le monde fondis pas comme
moi je pensais que ça allait mieux
marcher parce que plus il est énorme
mais c'est malik et la question fait
quelques choix de tf1 on va demander à
nicolas pernikoff grand professionnel
s'il en est de la masse solaire csp ou
ce qu'il en reste
[Applaudissements]
moi j'aimerais comprendre parce que
honnêtement qu'est ce qui a pu pousser
tf1 mes choix c'est sûr aux et en même
temps c'est un pari il faut reconnaître
ce qui est mais non c'est pas un pari
c'est une erreur stratégique
est ce que vous savez quel a été l
audience de la journée de tf1 hier
mauvaise pour sans cesse du riz à oui
alors que tf1 fait entre 18 et 20%
d'audience et qu'en france 2 hier
faisait 14.7 d'audience ça veut dire un
point et me d'écarts c'est un accident
industriel
c'est une erreur stratégique vous pouvez
pas mettre ce programme en prime time
qui connaît malik bentalha populaire en
l'occurrence là en l'occurrence c'est
comme si vous décidiez de remettre
qu'eva dams au mois de février en prime
time sur tf1 sur un show de ce genre
vous auriez exactement le même genre
d'accident industriel
vous feriez 2 millions de
téléspectateurs pas plus ça s'adresse
aux jeunes francesca le disais pourquoi
avoir fait ça je le problème aussi on va
avancer dans le débat c'est que ils ont
commencé le spectacle réellement je
crois à 21h25 y avait un pré show
dramatique bas merci traduit par camille
combal mais on va regarder un petit bout
du pré show c'est l'événement ce soir
bienvenue à tous sur tf1 malik bentalha
va jouer son spectacle encore en direct
pour vous tout le monde est en train de
se préparer tout le monde en train de
s'acharner à quelques secondes seulement
de découvrir malik sur scène ya des gens
qui sont un petit peu perdu qu'est ce
qui vous arrive mademoiselle c'est pas
votre attend des baisses c'est juste là
mais parce qu'il vous l'a pris excuse
moi mon grand c'est la place de la
demande pardon cette patrie curie mais
moi j'aime et poste depuis six mois
voilà environ malika encore encore une
fois on mais on m'indique les recettes
en place il n'y a pas de souci par
désolé j'ai fait dit j'ai dû faire parce
que parfois les chiffres aussi ça autant
pour moi pour vous revenir sur ce que
vient de dire tout à l'heure francesca
pour rebondir en effet si les jeunes
surtout qui regardent malik bentalha et
faut pas se mentir les jeunes regardent
quasiment plus la télé donc qui regarde
c'est aussi les personnes
âgé qui connaissent pas du tout la plus
basse a recommandé un peu dans le wagon
index a effrayé les week-ends
franchement il ya une question je me
pose c'est aujourd'hui des axes
identifiés elle de tf1 on en est pas au
premier aujourd'hui tu as un va mal
pourquoi on maintient cette direction il
ya quand même aujourd'hui des chaînes on
ne laisse plus les directions
s'installer à tremblay a réfléchi mais
faut dire sereine tf1 on va dire pour
être au quotidien dans tout l'est la
jouerie avec ce revers jamais en
question dans la direction de tf1
pourquoi ces gens là sont encore en
place aujourd'hui les accidents trudel
se multiplient les choix des programmes
on se demande parfois qu'est ce que
c'est qu'est-ce que sa direction a amené
aujourd'hui à la chaîne à part aller
pomper des animateurs qui n'a d'autre
part ou de faire des spin off des
missions qui nous arrive est autre chose
vous imaginez il formalise surtour malik
le réveil de ce matin c'est une fois
j'ai pensé volume du hockey alors il
pour coiffer et maquiller sur
intéressante analyse et pendant toute la
soirée
on vous attend talât en premières
tendances top tuer tant que numéro un
des plus commentés en france ça veut
dire que n'y a aucune corrélation en or
le seul commentaire
et l'audience à la terre y avait trop de
pub trop de vue convoi de mme à
l'emmental à trois secondes entre deux
écrans de pub au cinéma juste parler de
ce qu'ils ont voulu monter en avant
spectacle avec camille combal qu'est
charmant qui est super sur certaines
émissions mais là quelle est l'utilité
de faire venir cabinet dewey on va voir
les spectacles de malik bentalha bas on
est au courant
il est venu nous chauffer un truc qu'on
savait déjà pour présenter ses toiles
c'est un problème de cuisine interne
c'est un calage par rapport à la
publicité comme elle est un spectacle en
direct
ils font cela pour pouvoir engranger de
l'appliquer à mon avis vu le score lui
qui vont rembourser demain matin à mon
avis mais les gens ont zappé sur ces we
saw sont barrés à la bombe à bagdad et
ils sont restés suis désolé après pour
mes cultures d'études magali berda merci
beaucoup c'est vrai que dans la
programmation de tf1 qui a une grand
public populaire ça c'est vrai qu'ils
ont enchaîné des séquences alors moi
j'aime bien mais je suis pas sûr que
certains public de tf1 est appréciée
avec eux d'enchaîner avec cet emploi etc
c'était bien et ça c'est beau c'est très
bien mais sur tf1 l'amour la gare on
attend l'amour la guerre
on aime beaucoup
j'essaie d'expliquer les choses vidéo
regardez on a les gens devant leur écran
et les garder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
j'ai une corde
besoin
j'ai envie de m'enfermer frci wenders on
citera les pôles mille litres des
baigneurs sont pas sympathiques et
récupère des longueurs
[Applaudissements]
j'imagine bien le public de tf1 qui en
gros à passer le rideau devant des 12
coups de midi
je demande à mon avis je trouve que
c'est bravo pour une fois à tf1 pourtant
j'aime pas cette chaîne je les aime pas
du tout mais justement ça montre autre
chose c'est de la nouveauté ils ont osé
malik bentalha soit une star sur les
réseaux sociaux
l'enfoiré c'est une star sur les réseaux
sociaux un peu de modernité ça fait
aussi j'ai connu à l'époque que c'était
dirigé non par nonce paolini par ken
block qui avait une vision de la chaîne
qui était juste de dire 'voilà ya des
choses très bien qui se font ailleurs
sur d'autres chaînes n'est ce pas
bernard montiel mais tf1 s'adresse à un
public extrêmement large alors faire des
paris avec effectivement une chaîne qui
était sur la première chaîne européenne
c'est très dangereux parce qu'à un
million neuf excusez moi c'est pas un
désert
c'est une catastrophe absolue c'est pas
que c'est pas le problème de faire
découvrir des talents ou pas c'est que
tf1 tf1 c'est pas son rôle
moi je dis franchement respect à malik
bentalha leur aventure on n'enlève pas
le vraiment le talent de malik bentalha
qui est un mec formidable je sauve le
truc c'est que le producteur a dû
étroitement négocié avec tf1 en disant
moi je vous donne malik bentalha mon
poulain en direct sur tf1 ok mais pas ni
tf1 ni quoi ni tmc ni quoi que ce soit
je sais que les négociations ont dû être
très dur mais ça spectacle comme celui
là moi je l'aurais plutôt vu sur w9
sans aucun mépris je dis ça mais c'était
vraiment w9 par rapport à la cantèle de
malick et et de notamment parce que le
même programme